en la izquierda Brasilia y en la derecha
Washington son dos imágenes que pasarán
a la historia similares en forma y fondo
siendo el primer evento de la actualidad
internacional de su respectivo año
Brasil 2023 la toma de los edificios del
poder judicial legislativo y ejecutivo
mientras que Estados Unidos en 2021 y la
toma del Capitolio en los dos países dos
líderes de extrema derecha derrotados
con simpatía mutua de hecho el
expresidente de Brasil Jair bolsonaro
apoyó a los manifestantes de Washington
y hasta tuvo un emisario allí lo analizó
en France 24 Darío piñotti el que está
encargado de Los vínculos
Internacionales Eduardo bolsonaro siguió
defendiendo hasta último momento no solo
que no se conociera la victoria de Lula
sino que se hiciera algo parecido a lo
que ocurrió en el Capitolio por lo demás
Eduardo bolsonaro estuvo en Washington
antes de los sucesos arengas de los dos
mandatarios y rechazo público del
resultado electoral
los movimientos populares actuales son
el resultado de la indignación y un
sentimiento de injusticia sobre cómo se
llevó a cabo el proceso electoral
[Aplausos]
para usar un término que a todos ustedes
les guste detendremos el robo
ni Trump ni bolsonaro acudieron a la
proclamación presidencial de sus rivales
electorales y después de las tomas de
los manifestantes si bien tramo optó por
el silencio bolsonaro hizo una tímida
condena en Twitter esto mientras sonaba
el ruido de la condena de la comunidad
internacional en Estados Unidos se
suceden Las investigaciones y juicios
con el expresidente Donald Trump en el
centro en Brasil ya se anunciaron
pesquisas también con el ex presidente
Jair bolsonaro señalado la justicia
tendrá la última palabra